I grew up in Seattle I've been working
in copy since I was about 15 for the
roasting side of coffee
I just learned by doing over and over
and over again my name is Brenda Malawi
I own elm Coffee Roasters in Seattle
Washington is a self-taught have been
roasting pan sometimes to get the
correct posting methods
I'm Jason I'm Wendy we are the owner of
king gongmin coffee we are one of the
few coffee roaster that roasts
traditional coffee we are going to set
up because we want to share how me I
will sing cup of coffee
is this great big story is by Singapore
Airlines a great way to fly this is my
roaster in my cafe what we do is we buy
just extremely high quality green coffee
from small farms around the world we
roast it lightly and take a lot of time
to play with it for me it's important to
roast our coffee one it's really fun to
do another thing is we get to control
the product from raw material to
represent it to the customer this is our
roastery we use Indonesian robusta beans
we meet we both our coffee beans up to
220 degrees then after that we need the
sugar to melt to brownish color we have
the Kara berry
about seven minutes that way it's ready
we had to mix with margarine to make it
more smooth teas Kavya is important to
me not only because it's like my
livelihood it's my business but it's
also a drink that is extremely complex
it's always perfectible and it also has
a social aspect Singapore coffee belongs
to every Singaporean is the culture of
Singapore is the root of our country we
believe that coffee is about connecting
people and how people from west and east
can meet over coffee when we met Brendon
she showed me how it was
lowest temperature and shutter times so
the protein cells is quite different
from Elvis and we got into the process
of making the coffee he brought it over
to the walk we cooked it with the butter
in the sugar it's basically the exact
opposite in some ways and what we try to
do yeah when we roast coffee we try to
avoid any smoky or roast flavor yet it's
not like subtle you know and drink it
you're like knocked out I'd be like
somebody woke up and like clocked me
across the jaw really okay cool yeah
okay we can see that coffee is
considered national drinks to everyone
in theater which is something I our
could be in Singapore I like the copia
more than that body would the dedication
to like quality in the process of making
it it's the same but the head product is
vastly different people are always
looking for the new thing but often the
older ways of doing things are better
it's unbelievable to see to roaster
meeting together having them to share
and exchange their roasting experiences
I think that's marvelous
[Music]